now this is really exciting I am
technologically hopeless but I can now
have a personal experience with the
Saint Edwards crime that will be placed
on the king's head by just tapping this
app you will see a cushion appear and
then the Saint Edwards Crown is placed
almost like the Archbishop will put it
on the king's head at the coronation
itself and then you can literally
interact with it as though you're inside
the safe itself in the Tower of London
you can go in really close and see each
of the jewels and it's your interaction
with an object that has been really the
embodiment of the nation's story
throughout history and it was created in
1661 at the restoration of the crime for
King Charles II and so you'll literally
be able to interact with what will be
placed upon King Charles III's head
what's fascinating is that the
Archbishop in 1937 didn't know which way
around to put it onto George VI's head
because in fact as you go around it
you'll see how similar it is from every
side
they came up with some very clever ways
to do that but I should imagine that
with any luck the Archbishop of
Canterbury himself can have this close
association with it just like you and
you can literally have your moment with
Saint Edwards crime it will be the
Principal moment of the whole coronation
when our King is crying with this crime
but you get the chance to be with it in
person yourself
goodness absolutely fantastic and it's
not just the crown it has to be said
alistair's here now hi good morning
hello there easy to do
I'm sorry easy to do no because I am
completely incompetent of these things
you can do it so you go to the app it's
actually built
um for a phone but I think it will work
um on an iPad if necessary although not
to the same technical level so I need to
tap on when I go to the website there we
go and then it says um tap to place
and there you go if you look on the
screen behind me coming up about now and
there it is amazing there is the crown
tell me about the crowd it was made in
1661 by Robert Viner for the restoration
of the monarchy after Cromwell and it
was first placed on Charles II's head
and so it's rather interesting it'll now
be placed on Charles III's head and you
can not on the iPad as I said but on
your phone you can get it to rotate and
you go through all of the medical chips
you can go around all the different
parts of it you can look at the Arches
close up you can look at the the jewels
now the jewels were finally placed there
by only King George V in the past I used
to leave it without jewels and they'd
borrow some every time there was a
coronation amazing now
um how have we managed to put this app
together
well I think it's the work of Atlantic
Productions I work with them when we did
a film and I had a conversation with
Queen Elizabeth II about this crime and
she interacted with it for the first
time since her coronation in 1953. it's
quite sweet because she tapped it with
her finger and she asked gosh I wonder
if it's as heavy as it was and then she
lifted it up it was quite interesting to
see her holding this object with which
she was crowned when she was aged just
26 in 1953 and it's not just the crown
is it that you can do
now the other objects which are called
the regalia collectively that will be
used for the coronation of the King on
the 6th of May
um okay and this you can literally have
this on your coffee table while you're
watching your excellent commentary of
the coronation which is a week on
Saturday of course that's right and you
can get up and walk around not that you
want to do that but you've seen me doing
it in that clip and you can literally go
to any side of it and I was hinting at
the fact that the Archbishop put it on
the wrong way around for George VI and
it's because the Archbishop will put a
tiny piece of thread on the front but
when the cleaners came around just
before the coronation one of them saw it
and took it off
and it's fascinating if you look at the
footage you can see the Archbishop and
the King wrote in his diary I never did
know if they put it on the right way
round or not well it looks amazing
whichever way it was and this is what
you can do you can have literally the
crown and it's only ever used for a
coronation correct so the last time it
was used was more than 70 years ago
that's right
um and you will see it happen again at
about 11 30. a little bit just after 12
o'clock after 12 o'clock okay but it's
uh our coverage will start at six
o'clock in the morning
um on the Saturday and then just after
midday he will be crowned King we can do
the same with the crown for Camilla in
due course I think they're doing some
final filming on that but it will be
added to the collection so that'll be
fascinating to see okay so I just have
to hold this as steady as I can on an
iPad but if you give it a go give it a
go on your phone you go to the website
you can see actually the QR code there
on your screen at the moment having to
Nodge because if I let go of this then
it's going to be all over the place
everyone is really steady uh get your
phone take it to the QR code have a go
and literally you just follow it through
it's just so easy
um to do and as I said while you're
having your Pringles and your small
Shandy listening to alistair's coverage
then you can literally have the crown
jewels on your coffee table at home at
the same time how cool is that very much
looking forward to seeing you a week on
Saturday it'll be great but fantastic in
fact everybody will know when the crown
is put on the king's head because
according to a lovely book that was
written for Richard II
the moment that happens the guns at the
Tower of London in fact at Edinburgh
Castle and other places around the
country will be shot off and they'll
fire the guns and everybody will know
it's happened and there we go um they're
also watching Sky News and indeed
they'll also know under those
circumstances I'll see you then thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot